Did you miss me?
After a three month stepaway, I'm here to
report back with what I've been up to and
share the tough but important decision I had
to make about the future of NativLang.
At the beginning of the year I announced in
a community post on YouTube and in text and
audio over on Patreon that I'd be stepping
away from NativLang for a few months.
I stepped away because I needed some perspective.
For years, I've jumped from project to project.
As much as I immersed myself in each new one,
it didn't feel like my job.
I was taking courses and programming to advance
my career, after all.
Getting animated about language history?
That's a personal passion, not a job job,
right?
Well, that question became acutely relevant
when I was well over 300 hours into animating
Middle Mongol.
What was I doing?
How seriously was I taking this?
Didn't this time belong to my career?
I couldn't shake that, even as I started pouring
hours into the next project.
So I cut myself some slack.
I released the story and art for Altaic that
I had so far.
Then I got some distance, time to learn, time
to create and time to reflect.
I was humbled to see you sticking by NativLang
throughout these months.
You gave me thumbs and hearts, and your patronage
actually grew!
It's amazing, you cheered me on and you took
the stress out of the whole thing.
I reciprocated, keeping you updated throughout
the months, including my classwork, opportunities
I was applying to and, most interesting, two
of my own projects I was building.
Wanna see?
While you waited, I worked on a custom language
builder.
Forgive its hackery-looking surface, but check
out its insides.
If I give it some IPA with features, then
some simple syllable types, it generates believable
words all on its own.
Then I can define some rules and have it apply
sound changes.
It even builds units by attaching grammatical
affixes or adpositions.
While you waited, I also worked Grim Harvest.
This is a prototype for a game idea I just couldn't
let go of.
This grim here farms heros or lite-rogues
that run through a randomly generated castle
when they're planted.
After I got the various game systems messy
but working together, creating the art and
music and seeing it come to life was an unexpectedly
nostalgic reminder of what I love
about creating NativLang videos.
And a reminder that I still had a decision
to make about the future of NativLang.
I compiled a list of over 100 questions considering possibilities
from going all in to walking away.
I spent weeks weighing my answers and
9 hours writing them down.
It comes down to this: I'm in.
I have a plan.
The plan is demanding but flexible with me when I need to set aside projects
or even step away for a moment.
I'll reevaluate in 6 months and again in a
year.
The plan overhauls my creative pipeline.
It'll take time to get the gears turning again,
but I'm on it.
Also, I'm going to be bolder about asking
for your support.
Since you're watching this I realize you're already more likely to be patron or supporter
so thank you for your patience when I do request
help sharing and sustaining my work.
Well, that's some hope and honesty about my
needs, plans and goals.
I appreciate you for sticking around and subscribing
this far.
Enough background, though - it's time to tell
a story!